seven years ago i decided to switch
careers and go into programming however
i did have two big worries will i lose
interest in programming and when
am i even capable of learning this very
tricky way of thinking it's been seven
years of work and over a hundred hobby
projects
i now have answers to those two
questions
it ended up being my best work related
decision ever made now i will show you
my latest hobby project and i hope it
will leave you inspired to keep learning
programming or even pick it up for the
first time enjoy
[Music]
every day
i spend so much time looking for the
optimal route
to commute to work
this is not gonna work being a developer
i have no excuses to not take care of
this problem
and make a nice experience for myself to
find the optimal route to work even
before leaving home i need to decide
between two buses and two trams and they
go from three different pickup points
and navigating all these buses jams and
different routes
wastes five minutes or more every day i
commute to work
so depending on how long it takes me to
build my own solution
i might be able to gain back that time
and then become negative
of time so the company responsible for
the public transport in gothenburg is
called west traffic
and they have an app that talks to an
api so if i just can figure out how i
could talk to that api i could build my
own app and then aggregate different
transport points together into one
single feed and then i could just figure
out the best route with just one click
that sounds amazing to me because i'd
like to illustrate why this is an issue
so when finding public transport
there's an option here
that has a bus there's an option here
that has bus and tram and there's
another option here that has just a tram
if this one is the fastest one then i
have to make a change down here because
that bus only goes there so then it's a
decision on what's the fastest bus to
take bus or tram to take from here and
from there i can go here here is the
second or third decision do i switch
here because here there are buses that
go straight to work sometimes
but it might be faster to continue here
and then arrive
here at the central station so the
central station has three different
stops that has different options and
different trams different buses so you
can either be here or you can be here
and sometimes you'll come with another
bus
and go here and then you have to decide
do i go here for the fastest bus to work
or do i go here this aggregates to me
having to google all these different
stops leading to so many searches in the
app that it drives me crazy every
morning so if i could do this with just
opening my own app clicking once on a
pre-determined search that aggregates
all these together
would make my life a lot better
so hopefully you understand the benefit
i could get from this app okay let's see
if we can get some api access here i'll
just do a
random search and we see we have three
requests the first one i recognize
that's just a google analytics one then
we have a request to api slash token
slash public slash new returns a token
then we have journeys we have links and
we have results let's see we have a few
results here we have one two three we
have six results in the list and we have
six results here so this seems very
interesting so we have is departed and
then we have trip legs trip leg has a
bunch of information here we have
something called line seems very
interesting as well planned arrival time
i think
this is what we're looking for in the
api so a good thing to try would be to
open this in a new tab essentially going
with the browser towards the api so here
we see a problem we have missing
credentials make sure your api
invocation call has header
authorization bearer access token but we
did see this request we have a token
here including
615e
so we can check if
that header is present here then
request headers
authorization bearer
and i do recognize
this token hash being the one that is
being delivered here so
hopefully if we just use this token
we will have programmatic access another
thing i noticed was that in the request
we have
a bunch of query parameters and they use
for origin gid and destination gid it's
some form of id for i'm guessing it's
these two
origin destination so probably i have to
dig out these ids connect them to
the names
that i'm interested in and have a
mapping in the front and between
the name and this id so i think we
should try it in insomnia we we try it
with this token just to make sure we
have proper access okay so we're now in
insomnia we can see that we get the
missing credentials
but if i take the token that i just had
in the browser we do get a result here
so that's great the api access is solved
okay so i created this configuration
file for the app that we're going to
build so first i dug out the ids for a
bunch of different bus and tram stops
here that i'm interested in i made this
configuration called decisions that maps
a name of what the decision is so this
is going from home to work so i have
three different options of
of getting on
public transport
three different stops
and the destination is work
so my plan is that it will be three
requests
all receiving different departures and
aggregate them in the same list of
departures and sort them on departure
time so i can get on a bus or tram as
quickly as possible these decisions will
become like buttons on a home screen so
i can just click
on one of the decisions that i need to
make and then
quickly get information on where to go
so now i have created a next api route
that works as a middle layer between the
front end and the the api that we looked
at in the beginning so from my front end
i pass to the next api in the query
parameters origin id destination id and
of course the public token that we need
to have to access the api so i build up
the api string the the url with the
query parameters we execute the request
and then we filter those results that
comes back because we don't want results
that where the the bus or tram is
already departed so we filter those out
we make sure that there are at least
one trip leg
and we make sure that of the trip legs
that we receive
none of them are cancelled or partly
cancelled because then it doesn't make
sense to to show it and then just return
the results and i plan to use
react query because in react query
they have dependent queries
so i would first need to make a request
to get the token
and calling this api endpoint will have
a dependency on that the token is
fetched first and then we can use this
one
so i will use react queries dependent
queries and then of course
we need to also
make many requests
and aggregate them together and react
query has functionality for that too
so that you can ex they have a they have
a hook called use queries
and so i'm going to code that together
and then i'm going to
go through that code as well okay so
let's take a look at how the front end
will fetch this data because i think use
i think react query can really help out
in simplifying a lot of this
so we use the react query use query hook
and we call this query token
and it's just for fetching the token
and we need to have a token in order to
execute the
the api for getting different routes
so if we look at
the route queries this enabled prop here
that makes sure that we have got a token
before we execute this query
because we need to pass that token to
the query
and this is not using the use query hook
this is using use queries because it's
going to be multiple we aggregate
multiple requests together into a list
of results and they all get
the same query key so they will be
aggregated in the departures query and
for each we pass in a different origin
id so even though we perform multiple
queries they will all become aggregated
into these departures responses it will
be like a growing array
of finished queries that will populate
the data of this array
so a react query can really help out
when you want to do multiple queries and
aggregate the data together which is
really nice
okay so i am now finishing up the ui
coding and what is cool about this
specific api
is that if you look at my typings of the
api response here
you can see that a drip leg has a line
and the line
has these properties
it has background color and foreground
color
so i can match
the real app how that displays these
lines
by utilizing the background color and
foreground color
essentially what they're set up is that
they from the back inside can control
how the front end is presenting these
lines so if they were to
like rename a certain line and change
the colors of it
and the frontend could update just by
the api changing what colors it sends
down
of course it's a little bit of an over
fetch
to have it like this because
you might do multiple requests and
you're always getting these color
informations on every request but
it might be a good decision you know
so i created this component called
line icon that takes in these colors
from the api
and that's how i got
the display colors of each
different line to work so in order to
make a progressive web app out of this i
added the manifest.json so we described
the theme color that it should be
running full screen we have an icon
and so on i designed an icon that looks
like this
so this is the like logo of the public
transport company
so i use that in the logo design and i
also added the doge
for funds okay so here we have the app
running let's say that i am in town and
i want to go home
then i need to aggregate
four different pick-up points so this is
exactly what i'm looking for with just
one click i can see all the information
and i can decide
how to which one to go to and which bus
or tram to jump on
so this is pretty amazing i think it's
so great that you can with a progressive
web app get like the
native app experience and the quickness
and the convenience of a home screen
icon that you just click and you go into
full screen and it's i just love to have
that power
okay so i think i am becoming done with
this now
i have all the functionality i need for
now
and i've spent around three hours doing
this
and if i can save
around five minutes a day by using my
own app instead
let's see three hours would mean 180
minutes divided by 5
would be
around
40
40
35 maybe something like that
so if i use this
every day
for 35 or so work days i could recoup my
three hour development time
and i'm happy with that because usually
when i build stuff it takes me too long
so it will take me like a year to regain
my time
and so i think this was a successful
automation project where i can actually
gain
so much time that i quickly can recoup
it and also of course
the pain is gone from using that other
app that is not optimized for doing
these types of things although it's a
good app in in all other aspects but
you can always
make it even better if you just include
your own specific use cases
um
so i hope you enjoyed watching this
video i hope you got inspired to learn
or inspired to start another hobby
project and see it through and finish it
and if you like this video please
subscribe to the channel thumbs up the
video
share the channel to a friend all those
good things
thank you for watching and i will see
you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]
you